Who almost played Haymitch
instead of Woody Harrelson?
Which famous musician tried and failed to
get his songs played in "Catching Fire?"
Keep watching to learn the untold
truth about the "Hunger Games" movies.
The "Hunger Games" series ended up
grossing just under $3 billion worldwide,
making it one of the biggest film franchises of
the 2010s. It was an impressive feat, especially
since the source material was still fresh in the
public consciousness. It wasn't a saga getting
by on decades of nostalgia, but rather one that
resonated powerfully at the moment. As a result,
the franchise had no trouble securing sizable
box office returns every time it hit theaters.
Given the series' enormous financial victories, it
might be surprising to learn how little Lionsgate
paid for the film rights. Back in 2008, Newsweek
reported that the studio shelled out just $200,000
to bring Katniss Everdeen and
her comrades to the big screen.
While far from chump change, that seems
like an impossibly low sum now given the
franchise's success. The return on
investment wound up being massive,
with the eventual box office grosses far
exceeding the price paid for the rights.
Nowadays, it's nearly impossible to imagine
anyone but Jennifer Lawrence playing the
iconic lead role of Katniss Everdeen.
The first "Hunger Games" film came out
at a pivotal time in Lawrence's career: her
star was rising after her acclaimed turn in
2010's "Winter's Bone" and her debut as
Mystique in 2011's "X-Men: First Class."
Plus, "The Hunger Games" premiered just
months ahead of "Silver Linings Playbook."
It might seem like Lawrence was fated to play
Katniss, but her selection was far from a sure
thing at the time. According to EW, the casting
search for the role spanned far and wide, with
at least 30 different women being considered for
the part. Lawrence was a top contender from the
beginning, but young stars like Hailee Steinfeld,
Saoirse Ronan, and future "Divergent" star
Shailene Woodley were also in the running.
The process considered performers ranging from
ages 14 to 24, and since there was initially no
frontrunner, it was open season for young actors.
Eventually, Lawrence — hot off her Oscar
nod for "Winter's Bone" — would score
the role of Katniss, changing her career
and the "Hunger Games" franchise forever.
“Thank you for your consideration.”
While not quite as extensive as
the hunt for Katniss Everdeen,
Lionsgate's search for a director to helm the
first "Hunger Games" was still quite an affair.
In September 2010, Deadline reported that the
primary frontrunners for the job were Gary Ross,
Sam Mendes, and David Slade. Francis Lawrence,
who would go on to direct all of the "Hunger
Games" sequels, was also considered for the
first film, but he was ultimately passed over.
It's easy to see why Lionsgate gravitated
toward each of these filmmakers for "The
Hunger Games," even though they each had vastly
different qualifications. Slade, for example,
was hot off of helming the third "Twilight" movie,
"Eclipse," which had reached a box office high for
the franchise. Meanwhile, Mendes didn't have
experience directing movies aimed at teens,
but his reputation as director of the Best
Picture-winning film "American Beauty" would
have lent instant prestige to "The Hunger
Games." Eventually, though, Lionsgate settled
on Gary Ross — another director familiar with
awards season thanks to his 2003 sports drama
"Seabiscuit." With Ross at the helm, a key
part of the "Hunger Games" equation was solved.
The casting for Katniss, Peeta, and Gale
took up much of the media's attention when
it came to getting actors assembled for "The
Hunger Games," but they were far from the
only characters in need of talented stars.
One of the most important figures in the
whole franchise is Haymitch Abernathy,
a former Hunger Games victor who's a
shell of his former self by the time
he's assigned as a mentor to Katniss.
The part required someone who could be funny
while also providing a believable sense of
sorrow and trauma. It's a complex part, but
also one of the most important to the story..
In April 2011, as "The Hunger Games" was
nearing the start of principal photography,
Vulture reported that John C. Reilly would
be offered the role. A character actor
known for working in all genres,
Reilly seemed like a great fit.
He could definitely handle the comic side of
Haymitch, and his dramatic performances in
films like "Chicago" demonstrated his ability
to depict vulnerability as well. However,
despite how promising the casting sounded, it
wasn't to be. Woody Harrelson was ultimately
selected for the part instead, and reprised
the role in all three "Hunger Games" sequels.
“Oh, joy, why don’t you join us?”
Once "The Hunger Games" became a box-office
smash, it was immediately apparent that the
other two books in the series, "Catching Fire"
and "Mockingjay," would be adapted into feature
films as well. Even before the first movie's
release, Lionsgate showed its confidence in the
franchise by scheduling a "Catching Fire"
adaptation for release in November 2013.
It was a bold move that showed high
expectations for "The Hunger Games," and
it also allowed for "Catching Fire" to
come out just a year and a half later.
“Now, because of her, they all pose a threat. Now,
because of her, they all
think they’re invincible.”
Just a few days into the theatrical run of "The
Hunger Games," director Gary Ross announced
that he would not be directing "Catching
Fire." According to EW, Ross admitted that
the sequel's rapid production schedule didn't
give him adequate time to prepare the project,
making him uneager to return. When Lionsgate
quickly got to work finding a replacement
director for "Catching Fire," the competition was
quickly narrowed down to two names: Bennett Miller
and Francis Lawrence. At the time, Miller seemed
like a solid pick, as he'd recently helmed awards
season favorites like "Capote" and "Moneyball."
Francis Lawrence — no relation to Jennifer — was
a genre movie veteran known for films like
"Constantine" and "I Am Legend." Eventually,
the odds tilted in favor of Lawrence, who
ultimately won the gig and went on to direct both
parts of the "Mockingjay" adaptation as well.
Screenwriter Michael Arndt hit the ground running
at the start of his career in Hollywood.
His first produced script was "Little Miss
Sunshine," which would go on to win him an
Academy Award. Right after that, Arndt penned
the screenplay for "Toy Story 3," making him
two-for-two in critically acclaimed scripts.
One of his many gigs after working on the
Pixar film was rewriting the screenplay for
"The Hunger Games: Catching Fire" — an experience
that wound up being a major challenge to pull off.
In an interview with The Script Lab, Arndt
revealed that the primary issue he faced
with rewriting "Catching Fire" was time. Every
screenwriter wishes they had more time to write
and edit their scripts, but Arndt had the specific
challenge of finalizing it just 12 weeks before
filming began. With such limited time on his
hands, Arndt needed all the help he could get.
Fortunately, co-writer Simon Beaufoy and the rest
of the "Hunger Games" creative team were there to
provide exactly that. Through extensive
collaboration, Arndt made sure that the
screenplay for "Catching Fire" was ready to go
just in time for the cameras to start rolling.
Ed Sheeran is such a popular artist that
it's hard to imagine anyone turning down
the opportunity to work with him. He's had
big success contributing songs to feature
films like "The Hobbit: The Desolation
of Smaug" and "Yesterday." However,
Lionsgate actually passed on the chance
to work with Sheeran on "The Hunger Games:
Catching Fire," rejecting a trio of tunes
that he proposed for the film's soundtrack.
In an interview with radio station Click 98.9,
Sheeran said that he pitched three original songs
for the "Catching Fire" soundtrack, all of which
were turned down. Sheeran also noted that he had a
similar experience having song proposals rejected
for the "Twilight" movies. Despite the setbacks,
he said that he still wanted to produce music
for feature films as a way of expanding his
creative horizons. Of course, given the enormous
success that Sheeran's had in the years since
"Catching Fire," missing out on the film obviously
wasn't the end of the world for the performer.
Still, having so many original songs rejected
would be a disappointment for anyone, even him.
It's easy to see why the third "Hunger Games"
book, "Mockingjay," was split into two separate
movies. Both the "Harry Potter" and "Twilight"
series adaptations had their final installments
split into two parts, and "The Hobbit"
spawned an entire trilogy all on its own.
It makes sense why "The Hunger Games" would
follow suit: after all, turning one book into
multiple movies means extra opportunities for the
studio to milk a big-name IP at the box office.
“If we burn, you burn with us!”
However, the official reason given by director
Francis Lawrence for splitting the "Mockingjay"
book into multiple films was to emphasize two
distinct tones in Katniss Everdeen's final
adventure. Lawrence saw the first "Mockingjay"
movie as being more "internal" — a quiet but
ominous political affair — whereas the
second film was a larger-scale war story.
For Lawrence, trying to cram these different
aesthetics into one film wouldn't have worked,
so he welcomed the opportunity to split the story
into two feature films. Of course, the fact that
Lionsgate got an extra blockbuster out of this
decision was a nice bonus for the studio as well.
In February 2014, Hollywood lost an acting
legend when Philip Seymour Hoffman passed
away from a drug overdose at the age of 46. The
actor left behind a staggering body of work,
having earned three Oscar nominations
and a win during his lifetime.
Hoffman's death came toward the end of filming
on the two "Mockingjay" titles, in which he
appeared as gamemaker and rebel commander Plutarch
Heavensbee. Since Heavensbee was such an important
part of the books and the "Catching Fire" movie,
Hoffman's death had a major impact on production.
In the end, only minor changes had to be made
in the wake of Hoffman's passing. He had just
one major scene left to film for the second part
of "Mockingjay," and all of his material for the
first part had been completed. The big remaining
scene was supposed to show Heavensbee meeting
Katniss after her third-act imprisonment. Instead,
the scene was changed so that Haymitch visited her
and read a note that Heavensbee had written. It
was a bittersweet moment for fans of the beloved
actor — a clear reminder of Hoffman's absence and
the tremendous loss that Hollywood had suffered.
For a brief moment, the cast of "The
Hunger Games: Mockingjay – Part 2"
included Lily Rabe in the role of Commander
Lyme. Being a part of the blockbuster's
star-studded cast would have been a big
deal for Rabe, but she eventually had to
drop out of the production, with Gwendoline
Christie replacing her in the final cut.
Such drastic casting shifts in productions
as big as "Mockingjay" are sometimes due to
behind-the-scenes drama, but according
to Rabe, that wasn't the case for her.
Speaking to Collider in 2021, Rabe explained that
when she initially signed onto "Mockingjay," she
didn't have any scheduling conflicts. However, the
shooting dates kept getting bumped up, eventually
causing an interference with Rabe's Shakespeare in
the Park production of "Much Ado About Nothing."
Since she had committed to the play first, Rabe
had to drop out of "Mockingjay." According to her,
the producers of the film were very understanding
and supported Rabe's choice when it became clear
she'd have to pick one or the other.
Though far from ideal circumstances,
there are certainly worse ways to leave
the cast of such a high-profile movie.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.